es un gran paso adelante según la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
bundeslier la Unión Europea que busca
una alternativa al suministro de gas
ruso en el contexto de la guerra en
Ucrania anunció este miércoles un pacto
para exportar gas israelí a Europa y
Egipto
en Ucrania ha dejado al descubierto
nuestra dependencia europea a los
combustibles fósiles rusos y queremos
deshacernos de esta dependencia queremos
diversificar hacia proveedores de
confianza y Egipto es un socio de
confianza
Israel y exportar grandes cantidades de
gaza Egipto que se realicuado y enviado
a Europa
la cámara
este memorando de entendimiento
significaba una asociación muy esperada
en la que Israel y Egipto pueden
desempeñar un papel importante para
facilitar una mejor seguridad energética
a sus socios europeos durante mucho
tiempo los recursos naturales han sido
utilizados para la división y el
conflicto especialmente en esta región
algo de gas israelí y ya ha enviado al
viejo continente por medio de Egipto
pero el nuevo acuerdo aumentará
exponencialmente las cantidades lo que
requerirá inversiones En infraestructura
y los funcionarios dicen que Podrías
llevar un par de años el pacto se firmó
en paralelo al anuncio de Rusia de
reducir las entregas de gas a Alemania
en un 40%.
es posible que haya notado que ayer se
redujeron nuevamente los suministros de
gas de Rusia esto aún no ha terminado
puede ser solo el comienzo lo que
significa que la independencia de las
energías fósiles y las energías fósiles
rusas debe impulsarse a toda velocidad
el año pasado la Unión Europea importó
aproximadamente 40% de su gaste Rusia su
alta dependencia ha generado
dificultades para imponer sanciones a
Moscú por la invasión de Ucrania